I thought legalizing marijuana was
supposed to take organized crime out of
the pot business news flash it is not
well a startling report from NBC News
this morning reveals that foreign
cartels embrace homegrown marijuana in
pot legal states the reason is simple
according to Colorado Sheriff Bill elder
they have found that it's easier to grow
and process marijuana in Colorado then
ship it throughout the United States
than it is to bring it in from let's say
Mexico or Cuba federal officials say
that Chinese Cuban and Mexican drug
rings have purchased or rented hundreds
of homes in California Colorado and
Washington relaxed pot laws provide
cover for cartels so is it time to admit
that legalized pot in the whole
experiment has failed here to debate
that question is Mason Verger
is a spokesman at the Marijuana Policy
Project joining us from Denver Mason
it's great to see you this is pretty
wild that we have Chinese Cuban and
Mexican Mafia / cartel folks renting
properties in Colorado in California to
get their product what's up how is this
good for the state's where pot was
legalized well this is actually
something that's been going on in every
state around the country for decades and
now in states like Colorado and
Washington and California what we're
seeing is that the demand amongst the
population in those states is being met
by a new legal market where the product
is being controlled it's being grown and
sold by licensed businesses and because
there's still that demand in these other
states that are not controlling
marijuana people are still producing it
and once in Mason they're able to
undercut the expensive I've browsed in
some of the stores in Colorado that
infuse lavender infused edibles HOSA
this stuff's expensive the cartels can
come in rent these places undercut the
legal pot and it's and sometimes a lot
more potent believe it or not and a lot
more dangerous and they
flood the market with that undercutting
legal pot not to be a problem I don't
know where you're shopping for marijuana
but if you you're talking about the
prices and the fact is that you can buy
marijuana for the same or lower of a
rate than you could on the street no one
is going out and calling around to legal
drug dealers or trying out on the street
corner I mean imagine if alcohol is
being said all right let's hear what
Colorado law enforcement who are
actually on the front lines here what
they're saying about this wonderful
legalization experiment the vast
majority of people that we that we come
across with these grocer or Cuban
nationals
they're organized drug trafficking
organizations who come to Colorado to
grow their marijuana Colombia is to
cocaine as Colorado is to marijuana do
you think that the state is turning a
blind eye to this I think they are
absolutely turning a blind eye this
experiment has failed and I urge any any
state that is thinking about legalizing
marijuana to learn by our mistakes don't
let this happen in other states final
thought from you very quickly well
there's a reason why Mexican cartels and
Chinese drug rings are not renting out
houses in the suburbs to distill whiskey
and bootleg it around the country it's
because it's a regulated product that's
why Donald Trump supports letting States
establish their own policies and was
working with Congress to pass a law to
do we'll have you back I think it's a
disaster but we'll see well our kids I
think you're gonna be on the front lines
of having to deal with this years from
now